empörung über demonstranten in berlin
politiker reagieren mit unverständnis
auf corona proteste ohne hygieneregeln
stagnierende umfragewerte und strategie
suche linken chefin katja kipping im
zdf-sommerinterview und formel 1 großer
preis von großbritannien spektakulärer
sieg auf der felge für lewis hamilton
sebastian vettel enttäuscht mit ferrari
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne für
den sport sehr gerne schön guten abend
das sei unverantwortlich und müsse
konsequenter geahndet werden so lassen
sich die politischen reaktionen auf die
großdemo in berlin zusammen fassen dass
tausende die korona regeln so bewusst
ignorieren setzt die behörden unter
druck vor allem angesichts steigender
neuinfektionen ministerpräsidenten wie
markus söder sagen die zweite welle sei
praktisch schon da lars boom sagt
berichtet es sind diese bilder die auch
am tag danach noch für aufregung sorgen
rund 20.000 menschen demonstrierten
gestern in berlin gegen die chor ohne
regeln ohne abstand zu halten oder maske
zu tragen
die empörung ist parteiübergreifend
dieses verhalten einerseits
demonstrationsrecht durchsetzen und den
anspruch nehmen auf grundlage von regeln
die regeln dann aber missachten ist
wirklich auch ein spiel mit dem leben
anderer menschen freiheit und
verantwortung gehören unbedingt zusammen
die freiheit sein demonstrationsrecht
wahrzunehmen und die verantwortung sich
an die krone auflagen zu halten
markus söder lehnt im
ard-sommerinterview weitere lockerungen
ab stattdessen fordert der bayerische
ministerpräsident eine härtere gangart
bei verstößen gegen korona auflagen
wer verpflichtende tests nichts macht
obwohl er zum beispielsweise ein
risikogebiet kommt wäre das verweigert
oder wer auch ganz bewusst gegen die
massnahmen verstößt der muss am ende
schon mit einem bußgeld rechnen
ansonsten hat das ganze wenig sinn und
läuft ins leere und doch kritik muss
sich auch die große koalition anhören
die grüne fraktionsvorsitzende göring
eckardt wirft der regierung in einem
schreiben an kanzleramtsminister braun
schwere versäumnisse vor
auch ein halbes jahr nach beginn der
korona krise in deutschland fehlen klare
bundesweit einheitliche regeln und ein
verständliches konzept das ist an
fahrlässigkeit kaum zu überbieten
mit den steigenden infektionszahlen in
deutschland verschärft sich auch der
streit um den richtigen umgang mit der
pandemie in der politik wie auf der
straße schauen wir auf die zahlen die
die politik zu alarmieren im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 680 menschen neu mit
dem virus infiziert genauso viele wie
gestern und morgen startet in
mecklenburg vorpommern als erstem
bundesland wieder die schule mit
präsenzunterricht das funktioniere aber
nur warnt bundesbildungsministerin
carlitscheck in der welt am sonntag wenn
auch in schulen schutzmasken getragen
werden
bislang ist das nur in einigen
bundesländern in den schulen pflicht in
den fluren und auf dem pausenhof
ein blick nach niederbayern dort gibt es
in mamming einen weiteren corona
ausbruch wieder auf einem gemüsehof 43
saison arbeiter wurden positiv getestet
alle infizierten wurden umgehend
isoliert tests in weiteren betrieben und
bei den einwohnern im landkreis
dingolfing-landau vier negativ aus gut
ein jahr noch dann ist die nächste
bundestagswahl in deutschland hohe ziele
dafür steckt sich die linkspartei
man wolle sich so aufstellen dass die
cdu auf die oppositionsbank gesetzt
werde sagt parteichefin kicken im zdf
sommerinterview
dabei steht die linke derzeit etwa bei 8
prozent und auch die letzten
landtagswahlen waren eher enttäuschend
andreas künast im plattenbaugebiet
prohlis weit weg von den touristen
perlen dresdens will katja kipping
erklären warum die beachtlichen erfolge
der linkspartei beachtlich lange
zurückliegen weil viele der einstigen
linken wähler inzwischen bezweifelten
dass die partei ihre inhalte auch
umsetzen können und nach vorn gesprochen
heißt das jetzt wenn wir ausstrahlen wir
können und wir wollen das umsetzen um
die soziale spaltung zu überwinden gehen
wir auch in der regierung dann können
wir mehr menschen begeistern also es
kommt nicht nur darauf an die richtigen
forderungen zu stellen sondern wir
müssen sie auch umsetzen und das
anstreben auch im bund das kipping
regieren will dass sie ein
der großstädtische akademische
wählerschicht anspricht sorgt
innerparteilich für kritik vor allem der
wagenknecht flügel hält das klassische
arbeiter milieu für vernachlässigt
vielleicht muss man mal auf in meiner
arbeit zu karikieren weil seitdem ich im
bundestag bin ist mein
arbeitsschwerpunkt die sozialpolitik und
von früh bis abends kämpfe ich gegen die
ungerechtigkeiten und zumutungen von
sozialer verunsicherung warum die linke
schweigt zu den
menschenrechtsverletzungen in hongkong
fällt kipping schwer zu erklären
ihr habe ihre partei verbesserungsbedarf
und vielleicht sind wir als linke da
manchmal so einer position auch verharrt
wo wir sagen ja menschen wenn alle auf
die drauf hauen müssen nicht gehen auch
drauf gehen sondern wir müssen dann eher
sagen bei aller berechtigter kritik
nicht ihr trotzdem das gespräch suchen
die linke habe das potenzial bundesweit
auf 15 prozent zu kommen sagt kipping
das hieße verdoppeln noch gut ein jahr
ist zeit das ganze interview mit katja
kipping können sie gleich nach und sehen
bei den kollegen von berlin direkt in
auschwitz war heute ein besonderer tag
der erinnerung an ein verbrechen der
nazis über das in deutschland lange
geschwiegen wurde
die ermordung von etwa einer halben
million sinti und roma erst seit fünf
jahren gibt es diesen europäischen
gedenkt tag der auf dem zweiten august
1944 zurückgeht
damals starben die letzten sinti und
roma in den gaskammern von auschwitz
birkenau natalie steger auch mit 96
jahren kämpft cilic mit noch gegen das
vergessen
sie stammt aus einer deutschen sinti
familie und hat die hölle von auschwitz
nur knapp überlebt
in nur einer nacht am zweiten august 44
bevor das sogenannte zigeunerlager
aufgelöst wird töten die deutschen etwa
mehr als 20.000 sinti und roma werden
allein in auschwitz systematisch
ermordet
vertreter von sinti und roma juden und
christen gedenken gemeinsam der opfer
des nationalsozialismus
es ist aber auch ein tag des mahnens wir
dürfen auf dem rechten auge nicht blind
sein
wir dürfen den rechtsterrorismus
terrorismus nicht als patriotismus
verstehen er ist eine gefahr für unsere
demokratie
wir sehen eine zunahme von nationalismus
ich hoffe aber dass die menschheit doch
aus den vorgängen hier in auschwitz so
viel gelernt habe
die junge menschen sind gekommen das
leid ihrer vorfahren ist auch teil ihrer
identität
ich überlege nicht nur was hier passiert
ist sondern was unseren leuten weiterhin
und europa und der welt wieder fährt
wegen der korona krise sind in diesem
jahr überlebende nicht dabei
deren berichte doch so wichtig bleiben
hat er schnitt jetzt ins all wegen eines
tropensturms müssen zwei us astronauten
einen anderen weg zur erde nehmen ihre
raumkapsel soll nicht vor florida im
atlantik landen sondern im golf von
mexiko in der nacht hatte die crew
dragon von der iss abgedockt es ist die
erste mission bei der us astronauten von
einem privaten raumfahrtunternehmen
befördert werden und damit zur formel 1
der flitz lewis hamilton von einem sieg
zum anderen ja heute war es aber nochmal
richtig spannend in den letzten runden
praktisch auf drei rädern kommt lewis
hamilton beim großen preis von
großbritannien ins ziel
mit seinem ramponierten mercedes gewinnt
er in silverstone seinen 87 formel 1
grand prix
sebastian vettel wird im ferrari wieder
zehnter und nico hülkenberg kommt bei
seinem comeback erst gar nicht aus den
startlöchern mit geplatztem reifen
rettet sich
im mercedes durch die letzten kurven und
hat dabei glück dass max deppen ihn
nicht mehr erreichen kann
ich habe nur gebetet dass sich das auto
um die letzten zwei kuchen bekommen und
dabei nicht zu langsam werde kurz zuvor
ereilte teamkollegen valtteri bottas und
carlos sainz das gleiche recht sebastian
vettel wird zehnter kämpft erfolgreich
auf den letzten metern um den einen wm
punkt gegen bottas grundlegend was was
was faul entweder bei mehr oder im auto
nico hülkenberg bei seinem comeback
schon vor dem start aus dem rennen der
motor lässt sich nicht starten
dritter wird schale klar im ferrari der
ehemalige nationalspieler sandro wagner
beendet mit 32 jahren seine karriere und
möchte im september eine
trainerausbildung beginnen
der confed cup sieger von 2017 war mit
bayern münchen dreimal deutscher meister
geworden
seinen letzten vertrag in china löste er
wegen der choleraepidemie auf und wurde
mit verschiedenen bundesliga klubs
bereits in verbindung gebracht und der
fc arsenal hat das englische pokalfinale
den fa cup gewonnen und zwar durch einen
2 1-erfolg über stadt rivale fc chelsea
bayern münchens champions league gegner
im achtelfinale arsenal sicherte sich
durch den sieg doch noch einen platz in
der europa league der mann des spiels
pierre emerick aubameyang zuerst
erzielte der ehemalige dortmunder den 1
zu 1 ausgleich per elfmeter und dann den
entscheidenden treffer nach schöner
einzelleistung perfekt die
ballbehandlung mit dem pokal hatte er
allerdings größere probleme aber das tat
der feier keinen abbruch
der pokal blieb auch ohne brille noch
das wetter morgen gibt es im süden und
südosten schauer und einzelne gewitter
an den alpen regnet es anhaltend im
norden ist es meist freundlich hier gibt
es kaum schauer 19 bis 24 grad bei
dauerregen um 16 grad
ab mittwoch wird es dann wieder sonniger
und wärmer
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 15 im
heute journals hier übernimmt morgen
wieder petra kastl und design tschüss
und wünschen ihnen noch einen
entspannten sonntag abend hier kommt
jetzt das zdf sommerinterview mit katja
kipping